si hace apenas unos minutos se acabó la
rueda de prensa en la casa blanca jen
psaki la jefe de prensa dijo que esa
llamada había durado aproximadamente 30
minutos que fue bastante constructiva y
que el tono fue para mirar hacia el
futuro para tratar de limar estas
asperezas muster yo decía y empezar a
trabajar hacia el futuro esta relación
que la casa blanca considera
importantísima no solamente en el tema
bilateral sino también para el tema de
las relaciones entre europa y eeuu en
varias ocasiones periodistas le
preguntaron en la jeta de prensa si el
presidente yobái le había pedido perdón
a más pero no por este negocio a última
hora que hizo eeuu con australia y el
reino unido- y es simplemente la
respuesta de la jefe de prensa fue que
no que simplemente la respuesta de la
casa blanca del presidente maiden era
que él hubiese sido mejor si se hubieran
presentado consultas abiertas para
evitar este impasse pero que no no hubo
una disculpa directa
de alguna manera alguna promesa por
parte de la casa blanca a francia para
tratar de llegar o de mejorar las
relaciones se habló obviamente también
de que la próxima semana vendrá de nuevo
el embajador francés a washington y
justo desde que llegué de mencionó y
resaltó la casa blanca empezarán
entonces estos trabajos con oficiales
con altos oficiales de el gobierno
estadounidense para poder mejorar la
relación que está ahora hablemos del
posible acuerdo de libre de comercio
entre eeuu y el reino unido- boris
johnson se mostró bastante dispuesto
pero de eeuu parecen tener más reparos
al respecto verdad
exactamente de hecho se le preguntó que
no realiza en la reunión bilateral que
tuvieron ayer por el johnson y el
presidente yo bailén se le preguntó
precisamente a boris johnson y a bailén
esto y pues johnson boris johnson
resaltó que efectivamente se han logrado
acuerdos con respecto al whisky con
respecto a la carne con respecto incluso
el cordero pero que siguen reparos
preocupaciones de protocolo dijo joe
biden sobre todo de cara al hecho de que
le preocupa a eeuu que en un futuro si
se logra un acuerdo de libre comercio
entre eeuu y el
reino unido escocia se salga escocia hay
algún problema con la excusa y entonces
recientemente de escribir y reevaluar
este tratado de libre comercio este fue
el punto entonces que más llamó la
atención cuando se refirieron al tratado
de comercio justo cuando se estaba
refiriendo a este tema yo balbín hizo
una seña y en la sala en el salón igual
para que se acabara ésta
en este diálogo que estaba entendiendo
precisamente porque estaban tocando un
tema sensible frente a este tratado de
libre comercio